one hello everybody this is paula shirt
i'm a medical oncologist and i work in
the department of melanoma cancer
immunotherapy and development
therapeutics
at national cancer institute of naples
italy uh
first of all i'd like to thank
nanostring and organizing for the kind
invitation it's a
really pleasure for me to be here today
to discuss about
how coveted 19 has changed an immune
oncologist's life
from optimizing our daily practice to
the target treatment of the cytokine
store
here are my disclosure
in the era of covet 19 the first rule
is uh to keep everybody safe what does
it mean
to keep everybody safe it means
to keep safe patients and healthy
workers
physician nurses
but uh what we can do in order to
minimize
any potential patients exposure because
you know
to keep patients safe means to avoid
the possibility to spread the infection
one of the first thing is to avoid
gatherings because uh
with gatherings there is a high risk of
infection
and of course it's important also a
triage in order
to recognize people with fever who can
get
symptoms of kovid 90 and of course it's
fundamental to use the dpi
but it's also important to prioritize
patients and i will show you what does
it mean prioritize patients
in our daily practice and of course the
test this is a
more something important during the
phase two after the first wave
of the infection
what i'm going to do in the next minutes
is uh to discuss with you what we did at
the national cancer institute of naval
so mainly
at my department of skin cancer and
cancer immunotherapy
so i just told you
that to prioritize patients was one of
the most important rule but what does it
mean
this means that we have a uh cancer
patients
two different stages and of course there
is a priority
and a different priority between the
patients with
low risk cancer in this case melanoma
or patients with high risk so if we look
to the patients
who need of surgery we gave priority to
the patients with
pt3 and primary lesion t4 compared to
patients with t182 with the lower risk
and of course high priority was given
to the patients where surgery had any
acuity
important um meaningful
so for those patients with the stage
three melanoma
or who needed the resection for
oligometer study disease
this kind of patients had the priority
compared to all the other
also for the follow up was the rule over
to avoid gathering was important because
you know in the waiting room
the gathering may be one of the
potential risk
for the diffusing uh the infection and
for this reason we use the telemedicine
we reach it by phone all the patients in
follow-up
and mainly the patients of course with
the
low risk melanoma and in case of
no evidence of disease of course we
asked that to the patients
to postpone the next visit but in case
of evidence of disease the patients was
of course admitted immediately
to our department in order
to check visiting the patients what
happened
looking to the adjuvant setting you know
that now in the field of melanoma
there are some important treatment
and we use it all the 12 weeks that
in general we need for starting the
agile treatment in order to optimize
the access to the to the hospital
because
you know we have the seats where the
patients are treated and
still in order to avoid the gathering
in for the patients who believe imitated
sometimes in order
still to avoid the gathering we prefer
the biroff and mac inhibitor because
these are tablets and if
we have a lot of patients who need
infusion of course this was a
one possibility to reduce the number of
patients
in the uh they are the hospital seats
for the same reason we preferred also
the longer schedule so pembrolizumab
when evolving
every six or four weeks still in order
to avoid
the seeds full of patients and to avoid
the possibility to
to spread the infection
but of course the highest priority was
for the metastatic patients for these
patients
no stop or delays for both
immunoterminal target therapy
and the only things that we did
is just to prefer the longer schedule
special issue for clinical trial because
you know clinical trials should be
conducted
according to the good clinical practice
and you know in this
moment with the lockdown with the um
the the possibility for patients to not
be able
to reach the hospital uh of course some
clinical trial and mainly fish one trial
are on hold and for the patients
who were already enrolled we are using
still the telemedicines for the control
visit
and in general in agreement also with
the regulatory agencies uh
uh what we did is uh to assure the
safety for
uh the patients who participated who are
participating to the trial
to maintain the compliance with the good
clinical practice
and of course to minimizing the risk
for the trial integrity and the quality
of data
a special warning was for some side
effect you know that the premonitis
are an important side effect from
checkpoint inhibitors mainly
the rgpd1 and in you know that one of
the most important complicates of the
covenanting is uh
the preliminaries with the the
respiratory distress for this reason in
the patients
with the sign of premonitis uh and
uh with fever so what we did is uh to
test the patients
in order to be with the nasal as well
but you know
in order to be sure that uh there was no
infection
by covering 19. you know also that the
biraffi
inhibitor can give a fever
and in general this fever disappears
with the stoppable treatment in case
that the female
does not resolve with the treatment
interruption
still we did the iron we're doing
another swab in order to be sure that
there is a no code 19 infection
you know also that as a
immune oncologist one of uh our
main concern in during this period for
our patients treated with check pi
inhibitors
was the possibility of an increasing of
risk
of pneumonia for these patients
but uh this risk is uh only hypothetical
because at the moment we don't have
any data available we also
heard from the visual meeting
at hcr experience from china
from still italy in the patients with
lung cancer
through the which equal inhibitors so
from france
from new york city that there was no
increase over deaths
we said effect in the patients treated
with the immunotherapy
there is also another important
consideration because there are some
pre-clinical data that suggests
that antibody pd1 could increase uh
the virus clearance these are data um
that came more from the the flu
but this is also something that we
should
consider
in fact uh anti-pd-1 in general
checkpoint inhibitors
could be also protective i'd like just
to report you the experience of
my institution at the moment we have on
treatment we check for inhibitor
uh something like 400 patients
and in our institute in my department
we got only two patients uh covered
19 positive at the nasal swab but these
patients were bought in treatment with
adjuvant
were asymptomatic and they recovered
earlier with a negative test in less
than 10 days so this is something that
we should
again take into account
it's interesting uh at the moment a
clinical trial in a french clinical
trial
the uh immunoid um that is exploring
also the possibility of anti-pd1 to be
predictive it's an interesting
randomized phase to trial with two
courses course one
with the patients with the uh mild
symptoms or asymptomatic
and core two with the patients with the
moderate severe symptoms
and the difference uh uh in this two
court where there is a randomization one
two one two one
is that while in the first chord the
better patience there is a nivoluma
magic pd1
in the second second chord the twos
leads one the gns of 561
is a chlorokine derived compound but it
will be interesting
to see the data from this trial
but what can also we do
as in moon oncologists during this
period of the coving 19
you know this is a the time course of
the
um virus infection
with coronavirus um immuno oncologists
uh
could be useful during the this part of
the host
inflammatory response phase and why it
is because
we know very well that with the
checkpoint inhibitors we can
get some adversaries some immunorelated
adverse event and as i already discussed
premonitis are some adverse event
that could be
something similar to that that happened
with the kovid 19.
and in fact as you can see for uh these
are
uh kind of immunorelated that the verse
7
but what we do uh in general is to use
hydro's asteroid
but in in some cases of uh
steroid refractory uh pneumonitis we use
other drugs like
anti-tnf alpha or anti-l6
like two silicone
we know also in the field of
immunotherapy
and male in the field of hematology that
the treatment with the car t cell is
able to give
another typical adverse event the
cytokine is a syndrome
and we know that in these
in this case there are some
important cytokines like il-6 that are
uh the the cause of
some adverse event like
hypovolemic shock or primonitis
and we also knew that
the arts by covid 19
is due to a condition similar to the
cytokine release
syndrome so it's due to a cytokine storm
where il-6 is uh important
in generating the respiratory distress
that is uh sometimes the cause of the
death of the patients affected by
covid19
for this reason to target the
hyperinflation to target
the cytokine storm may be an important
strategy
in order to cure to treat
the uh arts by kovid
19 and for sure the possibility to use
and the year six it may be something
of crucial indeed
il-6 may have several important rule
in the inflammation immunity and
as you can see ir6 have several
important action on the several
immunosystem cells but not only even in
the puzzle hepatocytes
increasing the serious protein in other
actions that are listed in this slide
for this reason to use anti-l6
and here uh i listed some of
the most important maybe as i already
said
an important strategy
when we discuss with some
chinese colleague about this possible
idea they told us that this was an
interesting year they
already treated the 21 patients in a
pilot experience
and interestingly 20 out of these 21
patients
recovered from the um covered 19
pneumonia
in 24 48 hours so this was a
really an amazing result
for this reason on seven march we
treated
the first patients here you can see
a male born in 1972 with a concomitant
history of a
cardiac disease hypertrophic heart
disease
and as you can see the patients was
treated with those elizabeth after three
days from
the admission to the intensive care unit
and
he got an important response in a few
days
here in additional uh cases
a young male born in 1993 with no
coverability
this is important because we have seen
in intensive care
care unit not only early patients but
also sometimes young patients
again the tosilidoma gave an important
recovery of these patients as you can
see here in this slide
after these important results we
designed
a clinical trial the toshiba 19
uh at moment still ongoing um
we are rolling the patients with the
covenant imprimonium
with oxygen saturation thresh in ambient
air of
less or equal 93 percent intubated less
than 24
hours before registration and as you can
see
the prominent pawn was the lethality
rate at one
and two weeks after its registration we
rolled the 330 patients
starting from 19 of mars and we rolled
all these patients in 24 hours this
just to give you an idea about how
important was the problem in italy at
the time
i've used the dosage of those elites
over eight milligrams per kilograms
that is classical dosage that we use in
the crs
of carti cell therapy with a maximum of
800 milligrams per dose of those
elizabeth with possibility
to repeat the dosage after 12 hours
at the moment we are waiting uh for
the results uh the data cutoff was on
24th of
april uh we are just uh um collecting
now
all the crf and the data should be
disclosed probably will be disclosed
very soon
in in the next days
there was a parallel study an
observational code
here you can see the patients enrolled
on the 31st of march
but at moment are more patients close to
3 000 patients um the difference between
this observational core to the phase 2
and here
as you can see the only criteria that
was
different is that even patients
intubated more than 24 hours
were were treated this
court will be also important because
we will get data from a source of real
world
evidence in this group of patients and
still look to the
italy map uh the dos elizabeth was used
largely used around the country
this is another interesting uh case as
you can see here
of our patients still were was treated
with the
uh docilizumab and we got a response at
the interesting part
is that the eg
egm against uh the coronavirus
appear just 24 hours from the
tosylidsumab
infusion so this is interesting
another interesting point will be
in the follow-up of these patients
because
uh here again this is a one of the
patients
was treated at the beginning of this
story
and after one month he developed an
important fibrosis we
we will see now with the follow-up if
these fibrosis will affect the
quality of life so this is a another
important issue that we will see now in
the next future
you know that at the beginning
before the clinical trial we used
oscillation
as per of labor this was a the
possibility to get
the drug but sometimes the drug was uh
not available because there was a an
important number of
violence requested that sometimes there
was a delay of
six seven days and you know that uh at
the time was very critical for these
patients
sometimes uh some colleagues in some
intensive care unit
you said the sub-q of two-series
and they got interesting and still
important response for
this reason we also used another antenna
six
the sariluma but dosage of 400
milligrams sub q
two values of 200 milligram is a single
administration with possibility to use
again after 12 hours another
administration
in a series of 15 patients here you can
see the baseline patient's
characteristic and also as you can see
several patients are wearing overweight
on obese so this
is important because you know that in
this kind of patients there is an
increase of production
of il-6 eight patients were intubated
while seven are not
intubated
look to the characteristic of the
patients who responded to sarinum
um not to the number of patients
intubated and not educated
all the not intubated patients responded
and they got an important recovery in 24
76 hours and even three out of the eight
patients incubated also recovered
look also to the median pf ratio that
was close to 300
not so bad and all these
15 patients had high baseline
level of ill-6 this was a condition that
we
consider in order to treat these
patients uh
in this group was 56.6 remember this
data then
then we will compare with the no
responder patients
the baseline absolutely impossible less
than 800 that you know was considered
important cut off as a negative
prognostic
factor high level also dynamic
uh platelets uh normal
and also the c reactive protein was high
and you know this is strictly
related to the il6 level and also look
to the
median over the neutrophil lymphocyte
ratio that was 9.5 in this group
here i'd like to show you some of these
cases
may treated with an important response a
recovery of the
respiratory parameter in 24
72 hours this is one of the case born in
1906
here an additional case of a patients
born in 1957
additional two cases
again patients who normalize in 24 hours
and here another page did of birth 1964
like my here
with another important recovery in 24
48 hours
look to the patient's no responder
characteristic five patients
all these five patients died all the
vibrations were intubated and looked to
the
hematological values
the medium baseline il6 was 56.6 in the
responder here
higher 213 also the baseline
absolute deficit count 500
lower than 800 higher value of the
diameter
a c reacted protein higher than the
responder and also looked to the medium
natural field lymphocyte ratio 19.5
compared to 9.5 of the responders so in
these patients probably
the cytokine store was really higher and
the twitter was not able to recover
this uh situation
probably more interesting are the data
from
uh the biomarkers evaluation in blue you
will see
the data from the responder patients in
red
from the north pole them look at first
to the crp the crp seems to be the best
market in order to follow the
the the patients the best prognostic
market because
while there is a decrease in three five
days in the responder
in no respond there is no decrease ir6
is not so good
uh for the follow-up because you know
anti-l6 are able to make free old
il-6 that is uh bound to the receptor
for this reason you
you you see an increase after the
treatment uh even the platelet
uh went down in a responder and
look up to the difference over the
neutrophil
lymph saturation between the no
responder and responder is a very
important separation the curves the
trend of the curves
is uh totally different again absolute
lymphocyte count is a stable with an
increase
in the responder there is a decrease in
the responder
and finally the signal feels that you
know increase
in the responder decrease in the no
responder
of course we need the data from clinical
trial there are
moment to trial one with those leads by
this office three another with sarina
means a phase two phase three
from uh these uh last uh there was a
press
uh release a few weeks ago
uh that anticipated that uh uh
the sarinu mamma dosage of 400 million
seems to be more effective
in the critical patients that are the
patients that even we consider for
the enrollment in dossier 19.
so in conclusion uh we believe that to
target
the cytoconcern may be important and
targeting the circumcision means not
only to targeted anti-l6 because there
are several cytokines that are involved
in this condition for instance the jack
inhibitor are important
there are several compounds
even the anti-il1 inhibitors
like this anti-tnf
tnf alpha mainly several compounds
another interesting category of
compounds
are the anti-ir-17 and anti-il-23
here are very important list of
compounds
and also james says f again
an important number of drugs
so in conclusion uh just to summarize
what we have seen
what i i said so
during this era we should be cautious
with no panic
of course the first rule is to keep
everybody safe
patients and physicians and nurses and
to target the cytokinesaurus seems to be
really important and crucial in the
treatment of the arts by covid19
having said that i'd like to thank you
for your attention